you know tristan and i definitely are
not perfect
do you trust him i mean i definitely
trust him
as a friend and all those things khloe
kardashian and tristan thompson
are once again going their separate ways
i'm focused on work and like taking care
of me my body and soul
on monday et learned details behind the
split
a source tells us the couple ended their
relationship a few weeks ago
chloe gave tristan several chances and
after new allegations
decided it was time to break things off
the two are on good terms and at the end
of the day
chloe just wants true to have a good
relationship with her father
the news follows chloe's most recent
statements about she and tristan's
relationship status
which were part of keeping up with
kardashians the final curtain
it seems from social media that the two
of you are back together
we weren't for season 20 we weren't
together
and then i don't know we just really
really became
genuine great friends with one another
but
co-parenting's not the thing we just
really i don't know it just was this
natural progression
chloe addressed tristan's cheating at
the reunion special
which was filmed in april beanbaglover
tweeted chloe when tristan first cheated
on you how did you know
he it hadn't been done nor will be done
again well it was done again
it was done again i know the growth and
all the work that he's done i know
all the help that he's got and the
constant efforts that he makes every
single day and it really wasn't an easy
thing for him but i don't understand why
someone would go through all that if
they weren't really serious and another
source tells et that chloe and tristan
will continue to co-parent true together
in a healthy loving way the source adds
that tristan was at a birthday party in
bel air on friday
where he acted very single throughout
the evening
since 2019 chloe and tristan's on-again
off-again relationship
unfolded across social media showing
sweet moments like this one with their
daughter true
what my daddy yeah
oh it's a commercial now he'll come back
meanwhile the couple's more
uncomfortable moments played out on tv
during part two of the reunion special
which aired on sunday
chloe opened up about rekindling their
romance
why did you take him back just for true
the first time when i had true it was
a very strange but not for the baby it
was just like the circumstances like i
felt so
overwhelmed and then i mean it just sort
of happened and i did
then have this thing like okay this is
for my baby
and no matter where their relationship
goes from here chloe said she just plans
to take things
one day at a time do you trust him i
mean i definitely
trust him as a friend and all those
things but i'm not someone that
you know what i need to find out
everything comes my way i just have to
trust
i need to focus on today and go day by
day i don't
really i can't worry too much about
everything else